know what do you think about Lincoln
project I think they're a bunch of
charlatans who are making money
you really believe that yeah
tell us how you really feel a little bit
but she's like you're holding back a
little bit even like look you've just
met McCain's campaign manager he's at
the head of the sure that tip of the
spear sure I mean Steve has had a
transformation he worked for George Bush
too he no longer is a republican he
can't stand Republicans he's responsible
for Sarah Palin in many ways and he's
always lived to regret that so I think
he's doing Penance
um
look that you know their beliefs are
genuine in that they can't stand Trump
and they want to build something to
fought Trump but now they have built
something to fight Republicans but the
organization itself was corrupt it had
terrible internal problems personal
problems
embarrassing problems what like what
just Financial are you serious I want I
want to hear about it well one of their
Founders had real serious issues with
his personal behavior in his personal
life and the way he treated employees
were his subordinates
who are you talking about no no you
don't know about this Rick Wilson well
I'm not gonna look it's all public I I
really don't follow Lincoln project for
a living but they've had a series of
embarrassing issues and issues involving
real financial problems in their own
organization
um I'm all for groups being contrarian
and for Democrats who take on Democrats
Republicans take on Republicans it's
part of our mix I just don't like that
one group
and so I bring the subs okay so maybe
let me ask a different question what do
you think about Liz Cheney
I like Liz ideologically for being a
conservative I have no problems with her
vote on impeachment that's what she
believed in that's what she did I do
have problems with her serving on the
911 Commission uh as 9 11 committee
because Nancy Pelosi asked her to do it
as soon as Nancy Pelosi rejected Kevin
McCarthy's Republican selections for the
committee no Republican should have
joined that committee no you're saying
911 the January 6th commission I'm sorry
January 6th okay sorry you said 9 11.
yeah I'm sorry the January 6th committee
got it um so again it to me it's
principled if you want to vote to
impeach Donald Trump vote to impeach
Donald Trump that's a principled
position and then deal with your
constituents
but serving on that committee
Congress cannot work
if Republicans can't appoint Republicans
to committees and Democrats can't
appoint Democrats if all of it has to be
done at the behest of the speaker
then there is no opposition party
everything is controlled by the speaker
she should not have let herself get put
in that position so she's fighting a
personal Vendetta against President
Trump which I understand
but I think she went too far so the
reason why I brought up Lincoln project
is
we saw how they went after Trump the
videos they make and it's constant no
problem and by the way be a good credit
to them I think they influenced the 2020
election a little bit I think they had
uh some influence I don't know what
percentage I don't know what number they
definitely had that information on what
they did okay they were very good
marketers what they made what they did
the part that's confusing to me is they
said they stood for conservative beliefs
now they're gone after the scientists
you know did you see the the they go
after all Republicans now yeah they are
not conservative who's funding Lincoln
project by the way I don't know they
were able to raise a tremendous amount
of Grassroots money a tremendous amount
of money from Democrats who viewed it as
a bunch of Republicans McCain people
going after Trump so Democrats like that
contrarian play and boy were they well
funded
yeah I'm trying to see if the the
similar names are behind the Lincoln
project raised a whopping uh 39 million
dollars from July through September
uh helping Fuel anti-trump and Blitz
uh yeah I'm curious to know who's
funding these guys is it is it uh uh
there was a guy in Ohio him and I would
always debate and he would say but
Patrick you don't understand I'm a
republican but Patrick you know I'm like
listen I'm an independent myself I'm
pro-capitalism I'm fiscally conservative
I'm about to leave me alone freedom I
have some libertarian Tendencies some
independent Tendencies and cons fiscally
um would you would consider me a
republican fiscally because I want to be
left alone uh economically let me do my
part I'll pay my taxes I'll do my part
but Pat I'm a republican but Pat I'm a
Republican and he that's how he conv
convinced people to kind of flip so one
day I say uh Carl
you can fool a lot of people
but you can't fool me man your strategy
on how you're doing it you're full of
[ __ ] is what you're doing I say I
understand the power of what you're
doing because people are listening to
you saying well let me tell you as a
republican I'm embarrassed on my party
I'm embarrassed on my party it's a very
very good tactic and strategy okay
because guess what CNN wants to put on
all the time anybody that says I'm a
Republican and I'm embarrassed of my
party so you've got what's his name
denzinger uh Adam kensinger and some of
these guys are go I'm embarrassed all of
these guys all of these guys Joe Walsh
our friend yeah we had Joe Walsh here
was a very friendly uh time that we had
him on the podcast but are they at this
point like non they're so irrelevant
that no one's following her because
they're still getting some traction on
Twitter when I see them are they
irrelevant are they not gonna have any
impact are they still effective I think
for those who are in the business who
pay attention and know about the Lincoln
Project's problems and issues they're
irrelevant
um but if you've got enough tens of
millions of dollars and you can put
advertisements on the air people can
watch and that has influence but I'll
caution you
our system is so